l'ouragan de rien de faire toujours dans
l'atlantique se dirige tout droit je
vous le rappelle envers la nouvelle
écosse au cours des prochaines heures
l'est du québec les autres provinces des
maritimes risque aussi d'y goûter avec
des vents forts de la pluie abondante
aussi alors dans les prochaines heures
vous allez certainement voir les
autorités multiplié les points de presse
en tout cas ont aussi atteint on va
parler à notre table et comme ce matin
avait cloué au point et marc david
bonjour à vous deux bonjour jours parce
que faut en parler à de la
responsabilité des autorités des
gouvernements quand une catastrophe
comme celle là qui s'en vient catane
ouragan de catégorie 1 l'aca peut le
faire des dommages importants
elle oui quel est le rôle des autorités
à son art c'est le premier rôle c'est de
la prévention ont prévenu sous forme
d'informations mais prévenir et des
légendes est habilité à être prêts à soi
demeurer chez eux soit
déménager à changer d'endroit leur
donner les ressources dont c'est le rôle
fondamental et l'autre rôle s'est
rassuré donc faut pas de diminuer
l'importance des situations mais faut
pas de l'empiré puis ça c'est très
facile à faire et un danger pour les
autorités publiques
donc faut trouver des façons de rassurer
les gens donc sans sous-estimer mais le
nom à employer on est très important
c'est ça il faut être rassurant mais en
même temps 0 gens qu'il faut se mettre à
l'abri effectivement je pense que qu'on
doit retenir c'est la proactivité dans
les 30 dernières années ce qu'on voyait
dans les yeux beaucoup d'apprentissage
des autorités publiques
on était réactif ou peu actif dans
certains cas et que ce soit en amérique
du nord aux états unis avec fima ils ont
eu de la difficulté avec leur lourd en
gamme jaws en 94 ensuite catherine donc
en 2005 et ils ont eu beaucoup
d'apprentissage parce qu'à l'époque des
cafouillages
on pensait que les gens y avait un
manque de coordination
lorsqu'on observe en ce moment c'est une
coordination vraiment importante et je
dirais de qualité le j'ai entendu les
messages clés 72 ans 72 heures
préparez-vous pour avoir de l'eau
pendant 72 heures est autonome pendant
72 heures et ça c'était martelé dans
tous les médias et je pense que et dans
toutes les formes d'organisation pas
nécessairement celle de la fédérale ou
provinciale
j'entendais hydro québec hier parler de
72 heures aussi oui c'est ça tout les
autorités qui martèle le même message et
multiplateforme aussi parce qu est-ce
qui a changé aussi au fil des décennies
c'est le fait que maintenant on peut
avoir les à lire directement sur nos
téléphones c'est super important louis
lancé marie besset
oui il faut être prêt à rejoindre les
gens là où ils sont la lunette
consomment l'information ça c'est vrai
depuis le téléphone sont fondamentales
donc mais parfois le téléphone
il y en a pas donc c'est arrivé aux et
de la madeleine l'année dernière et
c'est là d'ailleurs que j'étais là
derrière
et la seule manière de communiquer
c'était la radio locale
donc c'était la seule façon donc c'était
c'est pour ça que dans les gestions de
crise les plans de gestion de crise et
il va y en avoir de plus en plus des
crises climatiques il faut il faut avoir
un plan b pour pour communiquer avec les
citoyens et c'est pas suffisant de
seulement penser aux alertes
téléphoniques sont non seulement cela on
risque de passer à côté d'une belle
occasion de d'agir et de communiquer
porte-à-porte ans quand on peut le faire
qu'en sens mais pas les équipes en
danger non plus et quand certains
conseils de porte à porte et donc moyens
je sais que monsieur david aux étudiants
sont aussi à lac-mégantic que lui il ya
eu plusieurs manières de rejoindre les
citronniers par la suite absolument tu
peux lui parler de la radio c'est
incontournable surtout les lignes à m
avec une radio on peut l'activer soi
même si on a pas d'électricité avec
créer un petit d'électricité et soap
c'est fondamental lac mégantic a eu des
ruptures de lignes électriques
donc au niveau des télécommunications
qui ont perduré assez longtemps alors en
gestion de crise il faut comprendre
qu'il faut pas se fier sur les médias
sociaux ni les médias traditionnels mais
regardez la radio du porte à porte donc
plusieurs formes des militants arbres
comme on dit aux états unis et sa il
faut voir ce même dans le clan à je
dirais qu'on traitait pas juste plus
envie mais plein à prévoir toutes les
situations tous les moyens de
communiquer de joindre directement les
gens qui peuvent être s'illustrer tout à
l'heure on en parlait avec le porte
parole du centre canadien des ouragans
des pertes d'électricité la dépense
d'électricité
il va y en avoir et possiblement pour
quelques jours peut-être même plusieurs
jours en nouvelle écosse notamment
est ce que les entreprises ont également
une responsabilité au plan des
communications et là je lance la
question à vous deux qui attrape la
balle en premier
je dirais que oui puis et 16 très
certainement ça fait partie de la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
de prendre soin de leur communauté d'une
part mais aussi de leurs employés on
prend dix né aux états unis note dans le
cas actuel
disney a été très critiqué pour avoir
laissé plusieurs de ses employés seuls à
une quarantaine de 50 kilomètres des
bahamas tout près de l'épicentre du
cycle alors la responsabilité sociale
des entreprises au niveau de la gestion
de réputation c'est de plus en plus
important vous avez des exemples aussi
de ce qui s'est passé avec de rien
n'était oui parce que il ya une
responsabilité mais il ya des occasions
aussi de voir comment si on est prêt
comme entreprise
on a des occasions de se mettre en
valeur j'irai en aidant la communauté
l'exemple par exemple super marchés
publics'' cette semaine qui était
présent en floride dans le sud des états
unis qui a mis sur twitter et il crée un
microsite pour dire aux gens voici où
sont nos ressources voici nos heures
d'ouverture ça va changer avec la
tempête parce qu'on aussi que les gens
veulent s'approvisionner donc le
supermarché public a très très bien
réagi un autre exemple moins bon c'est
celui de l'aéroport de miami
donc mr au port de miami mais en ligne
des alertes et s'il ya des images qui
sont 1 qui sont mises en espagnol et en
anglais mais on l'y voit pas faux bond
les voies pour faut cliquer dessus
jochen une image de tempête absolument
effroyable un gros est clair c'est pas
du tout rassuré et pour ça le travail
l'aéroport donc et c'est le travail de
l'aéroport a été de rassurer les gens d
informer les rassurer donc donc
l'aéroport miami c'est un c'est une note
n'a pas la note de passage
[Rires]
oui c'est ça et là on est à quelques
jours du déclenchement électorale c'est
clair si le 15 septembre prochain
si vous étiez candidat est ce que c'est
un mode où est-ce qu'on doit aller par
la suite aux et de la madeleine
halifax est ce qu'on doit aller voir les
sinistrés marqué c'est une question à
double
double aspect c'est à dire que
effectivement si les les politiques vont
sur place pendant la crise ça peut être
très mal perçu ce que l'on va voir on va
percevoir sa com' d'opportuniste par
contre a posteriori lorsque tout est
réglé puis dire qu'on contribue plus il
peut y avoir des messages peut avoir des
actions qui ont été prises au préalable
sans aller sur place parce que c'est les
premiers intervenants qui doivent avoir
toute la place donc pour moi c'est à
double tranchant même de déclencher les
élections c'est vrai que le
déclenchement des élections ça peut
paraître insensible quoique le premier
ministre quelques jours de jeu on n'est
pas beaucoup
donc à un moment donné il va falloir y
aller quand pète pas tempête mais mon
équipe de campagne aurait déjà la
commande de dire dès que la déclarant
pas été passé il faut changer le plan de
tournée s'assurer qu'on est là sur place
mais ça je suis certain qu'il ya des
équipes de campagne qui préparent des
tournées à halifax